the honey of my lip 9 bees native to the
area is especially sweet in the Mayan
village communities of Mexico's Yucatan
Peninsula beekeeping has a long
tradition Gabrielle Eck learned the
craft from his father the honey is sold
all over Mexico and even exported to
Europe you know they how you get so
smooth with us we can earn a lot in a
season where the yield is good even
though we have to invest and buy all the
equipment boy doll ademas but it's
working because it's better than what we
dern farming the fields for instance in
a people to like and I've me to
perforate inflow the 150 or so villagers
in which and Balaam don't have many ways
of earning money most earn a living from
their fields more and more of the forest
has been cleared to create them Luciana
Ludlow from the International Union for
Conservation of Nature is working with
the villagers asking them about their
incomes its hope the data will help them
find other sources of income that
protect the forest okay yeah no antibody
ver SI daca Monte there's already less
biodiversity than before we have fewer
species both of flora and fauna the
decrease is widespread and significant
problem in teh the villages use some
species as food or they use the trees
for their houses tanto para comer como
para sus casas
every year thousands of hectares of
forest in Yucatan go up in flames to
create space for agriculture often the
farmers don't even use the fields
themselves instead they've least them to
wealthy investors from all over the
country who farm crops such as melons
environmentalist Corrado Garcia from the
pronator organization fears intensive
farming will spread education de mexico
in Mexico's current situation there are
many other sources of income so they
rely on profits of this kind in
political ecologically this kind of
cultivation is enviable because
monocultures deplete the soil and
pesticides pollute the water the
contamination violets a source of
employment pero también es una fuente de
empleo Nadia what can be done to
counteract that one possibility is to
make farming more diversified again and
in that way improve the incomes of the
small farmers of Yucatan